I'm Bambi Francisco.
More than one hundred million dollars is spent on the virtual world known as Cyworlds.
Cyworld is one of the most popular social network sites in Korea...
...and joining me to talk about that hot asset in the company's moves into the US...
...is Henry Chon, CEO of Cyworld, USA.
Henry, Cyworld launched in the US recently...
...but let's just talk about Korea because that's where it's really popular.
300 thousand dollars is spent daily on that site just for merchandise.
What are the Cyworld members buying?
Typically, it's a digital assets that we created with graphics people...
...that represents anything between household items or paintings or...
...anything that you can use to decorate your space, that's called mini - room.
There are couches and there are dining tables and anything that you like to sort of say,...
..."This is me in the virtual world,"...
...in a self - explanatory way.
How much is the virtual Picasso go for?
I think, last time I checked it's about a dollar. These items are anywhere between...
...ten cents to a dollar, maybe two, typically on the lower end rather than the high end.
Do you have to pay the copyright fee for that?
We did, yes. We worked with the copyright owners to make sure that their rights were protected.
Now, I can foresee a lot of members becoming virtual designers and creating their own label...
Right.
...and selling their designer label handbags or rugs or home furnishings.
Is that what they can do today?
Not right now, but I think that's where we're going with our services.
So far, we had about 3,000 designers and content providers that are creating anything...
...that we sell. But, you know, there's always a demand by our user and community to say,...
...you know, "I am really good at creating these things. I like to share these with other people."
So we are trying to create a place where we can share those kinds of things.
And the creators of the content are protected in some way by a profit sharing or some kind of revenue sharing.